come from
can i guess
uh
so
thank you
okay don't open this up don't go like
that
you you move your body and that was
enough see
so boom then that is gonna just roll
from
contact around
okay try it
and then when you're in again
don't do it with force by not going down
you're going to ride the energy down
come around
some of you are overshooting the elbow
you're going like that
thank you very much they have to work
boom you're going to like pedal
it's just kind of like machio tush here
so the hands
weren't in pedals okay
you can't use your arm to get up
so he punches and that's a different
energy picture he brings his arm in
right he's using it to get up right
that's a different energy print i
wouldn't go you don't go for a cut again
he brings his arm in
right and you can come around and make
it tighter
he brings his arm in is that dinner yang
yeah
he brings his arm in so you have you can
go in right
so this is just a an abstract version of
a thrust
so he could if this is a knife right if
he has a knife
i'm not going to go in because that
knife is out here
so these are just abstractions
he throws a kick it's the same thing
okay so don't get confused like uh
i'm trying to do a self-defense
technique you're just working with
linear thrust
you understand so that is the
requirement of okay
you cannot upload i have to keep the
abstraction going and i can't get up
like that you understand
also physically shouldn't you be able to
get up on your own
right okay
if you want some operational fitness you
should be able to do that
if you can't do that what do you got to
do
exercise right what do you want in your
exercise
straight flexibility all right let's go
okay so now you have your responses you
get me
and your job is to understand that if i
do put against here i'm in trouble
right he has a knife on the other hand
he punches me the eye slices me
okay so when i do the technique i know
i'm gonna roll him around i can't let
him get up
and i can't let him come around or i
lose my
angle of cancellation so as i'm doing
the technique
i am aware of that
you see don't let him up all the way
don't let him rest on his back either
that's the same problem
so we go
he should go all the way over
no time to give up your angle
translation on the cross lateral arm
okay let's go
you